so my secret mission is to teach
everybody that you don't have to be
subject to the thoughts that are in your
head about you that say nasty things
about you all the time that's a good one
like yeah we are these amazing
phenomenal beings
but apparently 85 percent of the world
has low self-esteem like most of us just
feel a little bit unhappy about
ourselves and our condition and our
world most of the time and that is not
because the reality of us it's the story
that we tell ourselves yeah and so you
have the opportunity to change the
relationship between the thoughts that
are in your mind like for most people
your thoughts just think you and that's
not actually the way it needs to be you
can shift that relationship with your
own thoughts and choose the contents of
your mind choose the story of yourself
and choose what you want to do in your
life
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan we
are at the transformative technology
conference we've been talking to so many
epic people that care about humanity
care about Wellness care about
well-being throughout meditation so much
so much I'm super excited to be sitting
down with Arielle Garten now thank you
for joining us on the show my pleasure
the founder of their use yes yes and
this is really important technology I'm
really excited to talk about it and for
you to teach us about it it's gonna be a
lot of fun so all right before we talk
about Muse is this like 10 years in the
making
it's a long time that's a long long time
in the making to you know to build and
the Muse is a as a company of inter and
interaction interacts on uses the device
that interacts on makes and then it just
interacts on make other stuff
we license the technology to Smith
Optics we made a pair of glasses with
them
um and you may see other things from us
over time but right now yeah it's main
focus yeah okay so yeah so that was a
good small bit
um we'll get there prior to getting
there who are you
how did you get to become who you are
today so tell us about that
big question yeah so my name is Arielle
um my background has always been in
Neuroscience design and a little bit of
technology and then over time a lot of
technology I was fascinated by how the
world worked and more importantly how we
perceived the world and how we could
transform ourselves through those
perceptions so I started in science even
in high school I had a job in a research
lab doing embryonic stem cell research
in like grade 12.
um and then at the same time I always
did Art I was fascinated by making stuff
I had a clothing line a little line of
clothing that I sold to stores around
Toronto in the New York and then I went
to school for neuroscience at the same
time tried the clothing thing have a
larger line and then kept going on the
science thing worked in research Labs
looking at things like neurogenesis and
ultimately tried to understand how it
was that we perceived the world around
us and we perceive ourselves so I began
to work with Professor Steve Mann he's
the accredited inventor of the wearable
computer totally crazy amazing dude who
was a professor at University of Toronto
and he had an early brain computer
interface system so a single EEG lead
that you put on your head that you could
then do stuff with and in the very early
2000s we started to collaborate by
creating concerts with our mind
so we'd have 48 people at a time all
with a single EEG lead on their head and
who would modulate their brain State
typically just relaxing and by doing so
we would trigger changes in the music so
48 people at a time could be creating
this Collective concert based on the
modulation of brain state
and we did a whole bunch of these and
like kept going deeper and deeper into
it and I stood back and said like wow we
are literally controlling the world with
our brains and the world needs to know
about this like how is this just going
on in the lab like how doesn't everybody
know that you can control the world with
your brain
and so I got together with my
co-founders Chris amini and then Trevor
Coleman and we started to think about
how we could really affect the world
with this groundbreaking Tech
the first thing we thought is okay how
do we show people that your mind is so
powerful it could move something
physical so we created something called
the levitating chair it's like one of
those 1960s ball chairs with a winch on
the ceiling and you'd connect an EEG to
the back of your head and by relaxing it
would increase your alpha waves and the
increase in Alpha Waves would trigger a
signal that would cause the winch to
rise and so you'd go like that's a good
one to the sky because that's kind of
what we do when we calm our minds and we
fall into the alpha and Theta states
that we kind of we do kind of get closer
to the clouds in a sense so that's a
that's a good one yeah so you have you
know like all of those images of Indian
gurus who could levitate you don't know
whether it's real or not and we're like
we could do this with technology we
could literally make a levitating chair
as you would relax and get into a
meditative state
and it was amazing
from like a Winship out of the hardware
store and it was totally terrifying
because you're like you could break at
any moment
um and then from there we said okay this
is cool like what's the biggest thing we
can do and so now this is about 2008
2009 and the Olympics were coming to
Canada to Vancouver in 2010. we were in
Toronto and so we created a proposal
that ultimately turned into US allowing
people to control the lights on the CN
tower the Canadian Parliament buildings
like basically the White House of Canada
and Niagara Falls you know one of the
Seven Wonders of the World
um and we're gonna let people do that
from Vancouver 2000 miles away with
their brain
yeah
these are great ways to get people to
understand that they can make change
like that and we were you know a tiny
startup of three people in a basement
trying to figure out this Tech they say
you got that contract we got the
contract that's a big deal and within
six months and a very small amount of
funding from the Canadian government
actually created this massive
installation that really let you do this
like you could slip on an EEG and sit at
Vancouver and watch a huge big stream
that was showing you live what was going
on in Toronto and you could focus
increase your beta waves and spin the
lights on the tower and then you could
maintain that focus and it would spin
faster or you could relax and then
increase your alpaways and that would be
the trigger to have it Glow into a
little pulsing star
and people all around you into like all
around Toronto would look up and see
your brain like you know this extension
of your mind projected all the way
across the country 1800 feet up in the
sky in the CN tower you know like was
the tallest building in the world that's
you
and so from there we said like
holy this is amazing like we have
the power to do so much with our minds
and so we tried to explore every
possible way that we could project
ourselves into an object and try to
interact with it
um and so we had like a Wheel of Fortune
game you'd focus and like the wheel
would spin somebody programmed a Star
Trek game you know there's this episode
of Star Trek where
um everybody was taken over by this
device that they put on their head that
gave them a head of dopamine when they
shot a little disc into a tube do you
know
anyways we recreated that
um we made a thought control toaster
uh a water cooler nice
beer tap like literally everything we
could think of we had an entire room
where as you would relax the whole room
would respond to so you would quite
close your eyes and then the blinds
would come down the lights would get
dimmer the music would change she would
fall asleep the blinds would then close
all these so all of these things were
incredible you know incredible examples
of what our mind could do but none of it
was really practical none of it was
really going to be a product that
somebody was going to use in their life
and what we really wanted to do with the
technology was change people's lives do
something that was going to make your
life palpably better every day and then
we recognize that through this process
of teaching ourselves to focus and relax
to control the technology we were
teaching ourselves to focus and relax
and we're learning to control this inner
technology and the best use of this
techno Tech was not to control the
outside world but to teach us to control
our own inner worlds yes yes and this
was you know the magic aha the moment
that led to this device
so we recognize that the best thing we
could do was control our own minds and
teach people to do that and the best
methodology that existed for that out
there that have been tried and Trust
tested for 2000 years
was meditation
and we all that know that meditation is
amazing you know significant gains in
your body your mind your relationship
like every part of the world that's
important to meditation can enhance yes
but like Nobody Does it very very very
small percentage of the world and a much
smaller percentage of the world actually
does it regularly and it's because
typically when you try to sit down to
meditate you sit there
and you're like I'm meditating you're
like I don't know what the I'm
supposed to be doing
this is kind of weird is anybody looking
at me
I think I should probably get up now
this really isn't meditating isn't it
I'm not good at meditating yeah that
meditation thing was weird seems to work
for other people but maybe else for me
you get the idea yeah so we wanted to
create something that was really going
to change that Paradigm that was really
going to show you what goes on in your
mind during meditation and what you're
supposed to be doing and make it easy so
we created a tool that gives you
real-time feedback on your meditation so
you know what goes on in your mind what
you're supposed to do and guides you and
then it's very data driven so during the
course of the experience you have a real
real-time feedback that lets you know
what's going on in your mind and then
after the fact you actually see your
data yeah so to us this was the best
thing we could do to shift Humanity yes
the best and highest application of any
technology we could think of I like how
you went from doing examples that were a
little bit more about just experiential
learning and playing around things and
showing people they could control
something 2000 miles away with their
brains to putting together what you want
to be one of the most practical uses of
being able to tune inward understand
what's going on Inward and yeah you gave
a really good example like we
talking people about meditation it can
be a challenge in itself people make fun
of you me all the time about it and it's
just it's very funny yeah you did that
that was that was that was really funny
another one another one I do is when you
like when you sit and then all those
thoughts come to your head about what
you have to do and then you're just like
I'm just gonna go do those things
instead yeah yeah instead of actually
just breathe why would I just I breathe
all the time
no I need to do that thing I need to
respond to that person I need to get
that email I need to go walk the dog
yeah and it's and then it causes anxiety
because as soon as you sit there you're
like okay I'm gonna let my mind go blank
and in that blank canvas things
naturally arise that's what our mind
does it's a generative you know organ
and so the thought that arises is
eventually I need to walk the dog or
something I need to do and then you have
a sense of anxiety that continues to
rise until you go do that thing yeah so
you've got that like dog walking Loop
constantly going in your head and your
anxiety is just rising and you're met
you're not meditating from that moment
forward yeah so we wanted to create
something that could sit with you and
teach you what to do with that and teach
you to say nope it's okay I'm going to
come back to my breath I'm going to sit
here that might feel like a sensation
pulling me away but rather than writing
the anxiety of it I'm going to
experience some sensation I'm going to
let that go and I'm going to bring my
mind back
and it's not easy to do but we gave you
a methodology to practice doing it over
and over again and actually build the
practice because one needs to know when
their mind is wandering and getting
notified about it and and uh and
it's just over and over again I'm just
so it's just because I've done have you
done proportion of medication yeah
just I just it's just very strange that
we are now you know using
in some extent it's weird to use
technology to help us meditate when we
ourselves are able to tell that our mind
is wandering and just get better and
better at focusing but it's also very
important because it on boards a lot of
people
into the practice
um so I was also thinking while you were
talking about your experience in like in
fashion as well was really important
with with the development of this I
assume is that you're
you definitely want something that
people are actually going to wear that
and this is tough because you gotta you
have to you have to wear this
well meditating while meditating and if
you want to you can wear this
more often than just meditation
so we have developers and hackers who do
that so there's an open SDK you can get
so this is actually a clinical grade EEG
yeah so there's two channels here on the
forehead fp1 and fp2 the references in
the middle fp0 and these are two
channels back here as well on the ears
yep so on your temporal of T9 T10 so
you're getting like real research grade
data you know we've done the experiments
you hook up a four electrons
four channels four channels um and
you're getting real research grade data
sent to your smartphone
and so we have lots of people who use it
to do experiments home experiments
what's my brain doing when we also lots
of research Labs that use it to do real
Neuroscience experiments so there's
about 175 papers that have been
published using these as a device wow
that's huge congrats thank you yeah
so then so then now okay now let's let's
get into this a little bit so this is
the muse one when was The Muse one made
um so it was released in the end of
2014.
so it took like five years to put
together the first
yeah it's it's
totally tough to do so yeah so there's a
lot of challenges along the way so one
you have to this Hardware did not exist
before this form factor didn't exist
exist yeah so we had to create an EEG
that was going to fit reliably on
everybody's head and good get good
signal Quality Dry sensor so when we do
experiments and connect and uh you know
see how the sensor the signal is on this
versus like a biosemite which is a gold
standard EEG system they're using wet
prep with gel and goop and this is just
totally dry sensor I saw yeah you push
it for more to you push and pull for
adjusting yeah
yeah the dry sensing versus the yep so
we had to create all the dry sensing
technology
we had to find an algorithm that's going
to there you go it's going to reliably
detect meditation Focus attention versus
mind wandering then create an app an
experience that has a metaphor that
helps you understand it so the metaphor
uses your mind is like the weather so
when you're thinking and distracted you
actually hear it as stormy and as you
come to quiet focused attention it
quiets the storms yeah then when your
mind picks up and you begin to wander
again the storm picks up so you actually
hear the sound of your own mind that's
your notification to bring your mind
back to your breath to come back to your
focus and where am I looking to get a
notification
um so it's audio feedback so this sends
data to your phone and then your phone
translates the sound of your mind into
the guiding sounds of weather oh so you
play a storm yeah or you play a bird's
chirping or something yeah so it is the
sound of your mind as a storm and when
your mind is stormy you hear the storm
and as your mind is calm the storm
quiets and others what do you hear when
the storm is quiet just like the gentle
lapping of waves oh just the waves oh
waves
the visual of this they they were at
brain mind
um
in a
October in uh in September
just wearing an EEG and then you would
see a a projector that showed the waves
or then clouds a storm oh yeah we've
done that for years you have been doing
that for yourself okay cool so it's
interesting that it's been we've had
many years of iterations of this so at
earlier on we actually had a visual but
meditation is a eyes closed experience
so we no longer have a visual for it but
we used to have literally usually you
literally have clouds and you could even
we would do it in a 3D room you would
sit in a room 3D projected with clouds
all around you and you could then as you
quiet the clouds move away and then as
your mind becomes active the clouds
return yeah so we played with
dozens and dozens and dozens of
implementations and is this manufactured
in China it is in Shenzhen known Shaman
and A really lovely Factory
Shaman yeah
in a factory that's like highly
supportive of all of those workers I've
been there many times
actually not many times my team has been
there many times I've only been there a
few times cool like the rest of my team
has spent months living months oh my
gosh that's crazy just to make sure this
comes out right yeah yeah
it always blows my mind too
yeah Hardware is very very very
interesting
because of stuff like that yeah
manufacturing overseas and yeah most
most people don't don't get that so much
now there's also obviously a software
component to this but let's talk let's
talk a little bit more about Hardware
stuff what was the battery life in this
one uh so it's four and a half hours
continuous use yeah that's great and
then
um the fit it fit really well it was
really comfortable you know it's very
comfortable and
so what else about the hardware should
we know prior before we move to Software
so these are four channels you said what
does it mean to have a zero a channel a
reference in EEG euro is measuring
relative to the reference so you want to
typically the reference is the ears in
older EEG systems yeah
um so you want somewhere where you're
getting your biological data because
your skin your your body has a
bioelectric potential yeah so you're
looking at the value of the brain
activity minus the value of the general
bioelectric potential
oh okay so everything is subtracted by
yeah got it got it so it's in reference
too reference too yeah
yeah got it got it because that normal
spot could be could be generating
a certain amount of
bioelectric activity
okay and then so that's on every EEG
isn't there every Egypt has a reference
point ref
and then a ref if you're hip to the left
if you're hip to the lingo yeah to the E
geolog yeah yeah
so how many of these did you guys this
is when did Muse 2 come out so Muse 2
came out
10 days ago
Fresh Off The Shelf
damn
that's awesome that's awesome thank you
congrats yeah thank you that's four
years later it takes four years later
four years later now
now before we talk about that you know
that Hardware upgrade
um
what is going on with the software on
the software side of things so you're
taking in electrical so your team
bioelectric signatures from the four
channels two behind the ear two on the
prefrontal cortex right here and then
you're taking that data and you're
making sense of it you're doing that
those electric scenes making sense of it
so now I guess walk us through what it
looks like to try and make sense of of
that data so what we're looking for is
focused attention versus mind wandering
is that is that is that pretty much
clearly what you're looking it's very
clearly what we're looking at nothing
else yeah no so you can't use this for
open monitoring okay so that's what it's
called open monitoring so there's
focused attention yeah
um like a shamata or a vipassana
practice yeah then the next step
typically is open monitoring so once you
train your attention on a single point
then you have this trained attention
which you can begin to move around to
the room for example so that would be an
open monitoring practice compassion
meditation is a separate practice which
is a separate neural signature where
you're you know focusing on your heart
for example and trying to engender
compassion yeah yeah so it's different
those are all different practices
interesting so so you have to follow a
certain practice when you do this yeah
so what this is built on is a focused
attention on the breath so you focus
yeah it could actually be any single
point which is vipassana okay okay and
it could be any single point oh any
point on your not just nostrils you're
you can go anywhere yeah any single
point attention but we say on the breath
because that's the most common so you
focus your attention on your breath your
mind wanders and then as meditator your
job is to notice that your mind is
wandered and return it to their breath
correct and that act of noticing and
returning that's actually like doing the
work of the meditation exactly that's
the word yeah that's the workout in that
yeah so in a standard meditation your
men begins to wander and if there's no
one there to remind you that it's
wandered and remind you that you're
meditating might be you know 30 seconds
a minute two minutes yes before you're
like oh right I've been thinking about
that problem of work back to bed today
yeah yeah with Muse it cues you
instantly that you've wandered within
half a second and so if in a regular 10
minute meditation session with without
technology you might get in you know
five or ten returns with Muse you can
get in 50 returns like literally 50 reps
at the gym yeah so it really hones that
quality of attention really teaches you
very instantly to notice your
distractions and bring it back bring it
back so people very quickly learn the
skill because
first of all you now know what you're
supposed to do and two you're really
tightly cued into what it is that you're
doing and cued to come back that's
really interesting this practice of you
know 2 500 years is uh they're very
adamant about keeping it clean and
and uh
it it's very interesting to think about
because I always think about how
technology like Muse can you know get 50
reps and instead of three reps you can
learn how to meditate much faster
um psychedelics are also very
interesting to explore while meditating
all these and it's just it's just
interesting I wonder if there will be an
augmentation to the like the passion of
practice at any point you know or
um because that doesn't that does
interestingly make a lot of sense that I
could very quickly in the first couple
of days Focus because I hear I'm hearing
a storm every time that it wanders yeah
and so we're not seeking to change an
ancient practice like all of that wisdom
is incredibly valid incredibly important
like they figured it out yeah we're just
giving you some training wheels to
understand what that process is yeah and
to understand and hone that process and
so as a meditator you're a Consciousness
Explorer you know it is your job to have
metacognition to be able to see your
thoughts yeah and so we're just giving
you some cues here to help you actually
have that metacognition yeah so people
who are expert like beginners love it
because they're like I don't know what
the I'm supposed to do and now it
makes sense and then experts love it
because you can actually get a new level
of perspective on your thoughts and on
your awareness
and the idea is you know you learn the
practice and then the whole Gateway of
meditation is open to you because so
many people you know I I know for myself
before I really like started a real
meditation practice
um I would read books about meditation
and be like that's cool like go to sits
I'd sit in a temple and be like I'm not
totally sure what I'm supposed to be
doing here but I feel cool being here
and it was only once I actually started
through using Muse really building a
meditation practice and getting it then
everything that I had read before like
2000 years of wisdom made sense I was
like oh that's what they're talking
about okay now I experience it now I can
go into this now I can I can start doing
open monitoring and actually do it
correctly now now all of this stuff is
engaging to me because I get it that's
in me whereas before it was just
external words
so you know the goal of this is to be a
Gateway or to be in you know to be a
mirror to be a lens it's not to be an
overall solution it's yeah it's to like
open the doors yeah
yeah
I like I liked yeah I like I like
talking to you about it because I feel
like you're you know you're really
you're really open to
to
all of the different
walks of them of meditation yeah yeah
and that's cool
um
so
so let's Okay so let's start let's talk
about software a little bit more then
um you know there's so many ways to get
up the mountain you know yeah yeah so
many ways so many ways to get none of
them are there's a million ways yeah
so so now okay so now what shoot this is
focus so you're talking about Focus
attention so yeah so it's about
um you're you're looking at versus open
monitoring so this is focused versus
mind wandering so that's reverse mind
wandering but open monitorings when you
take the signal that you're receiving
from a channel and that you're able to
analyze a bunch of different things with
it
so we don't do that with The Muse
correct that's the skill that you then
learn that your technology lets you do
yeah yeah so normal EEG headset when I'm
putting on a normal whatever 48 or
whatever channels there are you know
when I just put on a normal 40 channel
AG headset yeah yeah exactly
so everyone does everything
when you put on one of those
um is that is is the
what I'm what I'm what I'm trying to say
is is an electrode on that is one of the
channels on that 48 heads Channel
headset is that
that channel is the same as this channel
right from the same spot on the head
from yeah so yeah right here on your
forehead if you put one of those 48
channels right next to it you would get
it and are you getting the same readout
too you are yeah okay the same signal
and then but your software only looks
for attention
uh Focus or mind wandering okay but
you're getting more information than
just that totally yeah okay it's a
clinical grade EEG so it's it's getting
full spectrum information and there's an
open API that developers can use to do
whatever you want oh cool but then the
Muse application The Muse meditation
application is specifically looking for
focused Engine versus mind wandering yes
we have another app called Muse direct
okay that lets you stream live uh your
raw EEG signal oh um or do real-time
ffts on your agency fast forward your
transform so that's how you take the raw
signal and you break it into the
standard bands alpha beta theta oh oh
sweet yeah okay so fft fast Fourier
Fourier transform take raw EEG data and
show it into from beta to gamma yeah
yeah cool gamma to Delta gamma to Delta
yeah okay from the G to the D the G to
the D okay
okay and then
um
so so okay cool so then your software is
looking for folks so now what is it now
what is what does it look like when
you're focused versus mind wandering how
do you what is it is mind wandering like
this so it's a like Fast frequency so
it's at this point it's a machine
learning classifier
um so we started by looking at the
brains of expert meditators and having
them note when they were in focused
attention when they were in mind
wandering and that's how we began
training then we added novices
intermediates novices doing the same
task and now we have millions and
millions and millions of sessions of
meditation awesome
um and so taking that and taking into
account you know what somebody looks
like prior to meditation and then during
their meditation we've built a
classifier that's able to look at
focused attention versus mind wandering
and it's not like the previous approach
was well meditation is Alpha with a
little bit of theta coherence
um we've thrown that out the window this
is like let's look at everything going
on in the brain over millions and
millions of sessions of folk extension
versus mind wandering and then come up
with a come up with the algorithmic
hypothesis from there cool so then okay
so it was uh people were going to a
state of deep meditation or focus and
then saying I'm in I'm in that state and
then or my mind's been wandering for a
minute yeah
okay
okay awesome and then are they wearing
the the audio is either coming from the
phone from the from the app from the app
on the phone um and then they can have
headphones in or not and they can hear
either waves or like lightning so we
actually have
two more coming oh okay so you can be in
a rainforest and so when your mind is
wandering the rain picks up and when
it's quiet the rain gets quiet you can
be on the beach and when your mind is
wandering you hear the crashing of the
waves and then when your mind is quiet
you know you it gets quiet just to the
laughing with water oh cool it can be in
a city park some people like the city
park meditation and so you hear your
mind busy like you know the busy buzzing
City yeah quiet like you know the little
bird sitting next to you oh that's great
yeah those are good really close yeah so
people choose the soundscape that most
you know they most identify their mental
state with and the metaphor is really
powerful I mean it feels like this is
your mind that you're you're hearing
yeah oh yeah that's cool being able to
hear your mind yeah that's cool you put
it and also you get to pick the
soundscape that's great okay
nice I like the design of the
soundscapes too okay that's that's
pretty that's pretty awesome and then
are we able to also um show the app as
well on on the show and then in the
meanwhile this packaging is freaking
awesome I really like this packaging
meditation Made Easy I'm used to the
brain sensing headband
is this French it is we're translated
into French German Spanish Italian and
Japanese is coming wow so we have musers
all over the world like we have millions
of users been millions and millions of
sessions of meditation with News That's
great so it's Global yeah it's great
that's great
mind real-time brainwave EEG feedback
heart tune into the heart rate
breath learn how to use your breath
to calm your mind fight stress and body
discover your posture to help wow
so so what's new about Muse 2 yes so
Muse two just launched as I said 10 days
ago and this has been the most
extraordinary Journey that I've been on
with my team in the last four years you
know we got the Muse Muse one out it
went out we're like oh my God you know
you're so nervous when your first
product goes out you don't know you
assume it's just gonna break and it's
just gonna like be garbage and you pray
it's not and it's shocking when it isn't
yeah yeah it's like somebody used it
three weeks later and like sent me a
note or like my life has changed it's
like what this thing even turned on it
held a charge this is crazy yeah yeah
wow
um gosh that feeling feels so good I'm
so happy you had that thank you a lot of
work that leads to those moments yeah
yeah there's a lot of like as the emails
were coming in there was just Tears like
wow like not only can this thing turn on
but people are actually using it and
finding value like that is the dream you
don't imagine the dream's actually going
to come true yeah is a long time so you
must have sold like a couple thousand of
them thousands and thousands thousands
and thousands of them and then at 299
was the price point it's so it came out
at 299 and then over time we've been
working really hard to bring down the
price I mean the goal is to make it as
accessible as possible yeah so now Muse
one is down to about 199 199 and this is
out for 2.99 and this is out for 249.
249 now yep so with all the improvements
in like the supply chain that we've made
during the last four years these two
with more sensors and even cheaper than
when the first one came out let's let's
check it out let's do it so this is the
baby
the box is much smaller than the
original
packaging's great thank you
for multiple languages yeah
so this is Muse 2 it's smaller wow
that's so small yeah smaller and lighter
than the original Muse wow
and it has seeing that's a lot lighter
yeah
dang this is very pretty thank you
wait did it make you write all of those
all that stuff on the inside yeah you
might even have a prototype on let's see
oh yeah yeah normally on the inside here
we have all the serial numbers and CE
yeah they have all the stuff written on
them on the inside yeah yeah this one is
actually even one of the prototypes
this is the muse one and then there's
the chain
and then there's two here
and this is like you know this is quite
thick in comparison to
pretty tiny for a you know yeah oh yeah
yeah it is yeah this is yeah compared to
this one it's just crazy that I'm saying
that I know I know yeah 20 years ago I'd
be murdered yeah
itchy that I can hold with one hand
too big
a lot thinner so now okay so now let's
let's unpack the
let's unpack this is this where the
charger is yep oh that's right so
actually that's super cool so that's the
charger and we brought back a feature
from very early mazes that we did USB
micro USB charge there and you can even
put two additional ports in
oh yeah so we make we make these cool EG
oh sure that plug into a micro USB so
you can add additional EEG sensors
anywhere on the head
CTO my co-founder yeah that's his genius
like USB extension Port that's brilliant
yeah brilliant brilliant now now we I
didn't ask you this how how do these
pieces of of rubber where's the how do
they sense electrical activities yeah
let's just imagine it's as high is this
IP
so these are actually uh conductive
rubber conductive rubber yeah so when we
were building this there was like no
obvious solution and we started working
around with novel materials and
ultimately created these conductive
rubber comfortable conformal sensors
yeah so that was like one of the big
leaps forward oh that's so interesting
so did you guys do tests on the
conductive rubber in comparison to uh
yeah so then we had to do a lot of work
in the material science of it to
actually get great signal quality yeah
to get really high class signal quality
because conclactive rubber in and of
itself is a not the best most consistent
material yeah
um so in this we used
on the forehead those are silver silver
chloride sensors silver sulfur chloride
silver silver chloride two Silvers
silver silver I think it's silver silver
chloride yeah so it's silver and silver
chloride oh silver silver and silver
chloride yeah and then in the new Muse
we actually were able to move to a new
material
gold so it's literally gold which is
better it's like actually gold better
conductivity slightly different
conductivity
and we weren't able to do gold early on
because the flex so this is a flex strip
in here a flex strip yeah so the
electronics are actually within the
strip yeah yeah and when we made Muse
and uh 2014 the technology was not yet
there to be able to do this level of
exposed gold sensor um interesting and
now there's just been technology
advances in flexes that has allowed us
to do that and this is the and that's
the heart rate all right sensor so
that's a PPG sensor so it's the same
kind of PPG PPG yep which uses light for
blood flow yes so this is a PPG sensor
here
and what it does is it shines a red
light through your skin and so it's able
to detect the blood flow and so as your
heart pulses you have more blood on on
every pulse
so we're able to see the pulses and then
the interstitial pulse and interstitial
with the red light and so we're able to
know each and every beat of your heart
so then from that you get heartbeat you
get heart rate variability and then we
also were able to do a pulse oxygenation
SPO T readings the level of oxygen in
your blood
and why why a PPG instead of the ECG
yeah so in order to do an
electrocardiogram you actually need two
points so an ECG is a metal electrical
sensor and to do that you would need to
get two points to get a true ECG oh
interesting so we actually can get
funnily enough you can do a true
ECG if you put the Muse on backwards on
your neck
because then you're going to get one
sensor touching the back of your neck
and you're going to get no no no like
this way sorry guys I I don't know what
I'm oh like this and then you're going
to get the other sensors touching your
collarbone and you're actually going to
be able to get two points functionally
an ECG like that oh that's cool oh
that's cool and we've discovered that
accidentally accidentally yeah
okay so in there we have a PPG yeah
um and so did the did the channels get
better on the
the gold the gold is yeah
it has good conductivity they're both in
terms of the signal quality from the
forehead approximately the same
approximately and then I'm still so
impressed by the rubber conductivity
that's that's so interesting yeah
there's a lot of Material Science that's
not simply conduct like carbon rubber
there's a lot of things there's oh yeah
that you had to make it more conductive
yeah
because the the interesting thing about
the rubber is that the rubbers what
actually makes it comfortable yeah yeah
so that's why if you figured out how to
put the there's a stronger electrical
signal by the
um by the back of the ear than there is
by the by like right here if there was
an EEG right here so what's sorry uh
channel right here on the inside of that
and so the thing is that in order to get
good good signal like you need to have
really tight contact to the Head bare
skin yeah on bare skin yeah no no hair
yeah yeah because hairs don't want those
microns to get in the way I want it to
be like they don't want my hair down
that way yeah yeah so with the PPG let's
sensor lets us do is create new
experiences for the heart
in the original Muse
um about the same about the same four
and a half cool
theoretically it should be better we'll
see we haven't been able to test it yet
to guarantee it yeah so I will say
safely about the same yeah yeah this is
what happens when your Hardware comes
out 10 days ago yeah exactly in a boat
from overseas
it's nuts
we've had somebody in China for you know
the last
many many weeks yeah
um and so the heart sensor allows us to
do some beautiful things whereas the
original brain experience is real-time
feedback on your brain we cannot give
you real-time feedback on your heart on
your breathing and on your body
you tell posture is that what you're
saying yeah yep posture and movement so
in the heart sensor the first experience
that we built actually gives you
real-time feedback so you hear the sound
of your heart like the beating of a drum
it's a beautiful experience so most
other heart things let you either just
see a little blip that's your heart and
you're like okay that's my heart cool
like that feels medical and monitoring
um or it's a number on your wrist my
heart rate is 67 right now but this is
actually a visceral experience of your
own heart and so you're hearing your
heart like the beating of a drum and
actually being able to tap into your
heart's Rhythm and strengthening just
sitting too totally and just feeling
your heart yourself interestingly not
everybody can do that is are you sure
it's just not like we can't like if
people train to do it they could do it
right so there's data there's research
that shows that some people are able to
when sitting actually hear the sound of
Their Own Heart yeah and some people are
not and those who are not probably could
train to get there but just
endogenously as as an activity there are
some people who cannot send their own
Hearts maybe if as you know if trained
and trained yeah I'm guessing everybody
can because once the focus gets so damn
good yeah then then you can listen to
all sorts of listen all songs
things yeah and so this amplifies the
beating of Your Heart Like A Drum yeah
the sound and then you can turn that on
or off if you want yeah and you can
begin to understand what affects your
heart you know and so once I started to
train with it I became aware when I was
anxious in ways that I wasn't before
because I could actually now feel my
heartbeat quickening and be like oh okay
this thing's actually causing me stress
I wouldn't have realized now I have this
cute for stress okay now practices that
I can do to calm myself down on the
moment and I can start to feel my heart
subside it's beautiful so we also give
you breathing exercises breathing's the
foundation of any contemplative practice
or many contemplative practices it's
also a foundational way to trigger and
shift your own physiology
so when you start to slow down your
breathing and manage your breathing it's
a cue for your body to go into Paris
parasympathetic nervous system instead
of sympathetic and so your body starts
to relax your heart rate slows actually
as you breathe in your heart rate
naturally increases and as you breathe
out your heart rate naturally decreases
so that's why a lot of breathing
exercises
exercises meant to calm you down teach
you to have a long exhale and prolong
the amount of time that you spend with
your heart slowing down
and relaxing your physiology
so with Muse 2 we now have breath
sensing technology that's able to
actually track your breaths
so you can track each one of your
breaths and also guide you with
breathing exercises so there's box
breathing
so there's box breathing like you would
do if you had anxiety and prefer a whole
for four out for four hold for horror
there's stability breathing short inhale
long exhale and there's pranayama
breathing you know fast breathing to
energize you so you learn a set of
breathing practices that you're guided
through practicing so that when you're
then out into the wild and you need to
shift your physiology you're noticing
that you're getting anxious or you're
noticing that you're too relaxed you
need to zip yourself up you know how
these practices that you can tap into
and your heart a physiological cue that
you can use to guide you as to where you
want to be at that moment
super cool yeah yeah the addition of uh
with PPG sensor to give you this data is
brilliant it's a huge addition to the
product okay and then
so then so then like you were just
describing all of the different
breathing you said for
for when you become more calm that your
heart rate
stabilizes your heart rate actually
starts to slow as you become slow yeah
and then you can hear your drum beating
louder and harder when it's when your
mind's wandering faster yeah faster so
we we have these exercises initially you
do the exercises separately so you'll
train separately with heart yeah with
breath with body so the body exercise is
beautiful
um the metaphor we use is that you're
sitting inside of a set of wind chimes
and so as you shift about you're
knocking into the wind chimes so you can
actually hear every time you fidget and
it encourages you to find a place of
Stillness and calm oh interesting and
for a lot of people for who meditation
is difficult or they're just starting
the practice simply learning to sit and
finding Stillness in their body is the
first step yeah and so we also have
posture sensors because there's a number
of different
um accelerometer and gyroscope sensors
yep
did one have it and both of them why is
there accelerometer in gyro so you can
do cool things like like helping you
find a comfortable posture for sitting
interesting yeah and then is that is
that so movement is determined by which
one the accelerator accelerometer and
the gyro both determine movement or
posture posture also you know
appropriate head and body relationship
and so then from there we can guide you
into Stillness and we find Stillness in
your in your body you can find Stillness
in your mind much more readily so you
train individually on these exercises
and then ultimately what we're going to
build is this harmonious experience
where you can simultaneously experience
your heart your brain your body your
mind we're not there yet
um but like that's that's the road map
so you get this total body physiology so
you're working on kind of like part by
part yeah so right now it's part by part
and that's like everybody comes in
through there and as you know the Muse
community grows and practices with these
pieces we're going to start to combine
them so we're always expanding the
software offering so when you get amused
we update the software like every two
weeks and so you're always getting new
interesting features that continue to
grow and shift with you in your practice
um and then is there another new sensor
or feature before we show the let's
check let's do it yeah software okay
let's show software so this is the muse
app and these are the features that with
Muse one you get mind meditation so
you're able to choose the length of your
session you can do a session as long as
you want it can be hours if you wish or
you can start at just two minutes and
that's a really key feature for people
like it doesn't need to be scary you can
just meditate for two minutes yeah it's
fine yeah
um then you can choose your soundscape
you can be in the beach in the
rainforest and the cities City
soundscape and more
and then we have a range of meditation
guidance
and so this is the muse Essentials it's
10 easy lessons that just teach you what
is meditation what are you doing with
this device how do you use it to your
best purpose
um so simple lessons like training a
puppy your wandering mind is like a
puppy be gentle and playful with it
um Deepak Chopra even created some
guided meditations for us and so we have
a bunch of content with more content
coming
and then when you that's a good partner
yeah that's a great partner thank you so
then was that like a little
um written looks like you can go look at
those different so those are all audio
guidance they're audio guides audio
guides while you meditate so it's like
headspace plus biofeedback oh cool oh
yeah so it guides you through great yeah
um so that's the Mind meditation the
heart meditation here you can hear hear
the sound of your heart like the beating
of a drum
and there's there's only one in the side
here but there's
a bunch of different lessons that guides
you through and there's more coming
in body you hear yourself inside of the
wind chime so that's right able to find
your Center
and so that's the accelerator and Gyro
at work yep and so there's
different audio there's different
guidance that's in there yeah and then
breath guides your breathing so for
example it's on the breathe in for out
four for six long exhale so there's a
range of different things four second
inhale success and so it's actually a
sound that guides you to breathe in and
out so you hear both your own breath and
the tone that's guiding your breath so
you end up sinking with the Rhythm it's
really really beautiful yeah
and then there's also timed meditation
so if you forget your Muse or you don't
have your Muse available and you want to
continue your streak we'll talk about
streaks in a minute you can just choose
a timed meditation and then just use it
like meditation timer awesome so it
becomes this friend this is on an iPad
but it would just be on your own phone
um this friend that's always with you
that helps you meditate and then what
are the buttons on the bottom and on the
top left top right so
here you have a range of different
settings so you can change all of the
audio you can change the guidance the
feedback you can turn off the guidance
if you don't want any you can turn off
the feedback if you just want to do your
own thing just track your meditation
without feedback there's lots of
different ways to play with it
and then the me screen
here's where you can actually see the
history meditation yes so let's just go
into one so there's a streak at the top
there's your streak at the top and
streaks are really powerful they count
the days that you've meditated and we
literally have people who've been on
like a 60-day streak in day 61 they
can't meditate and they call us they're
like can you just like Smooth it over so
I can keep my streaks it's a really
powerful way to keep yourself meditating
yeah you know the kids used to send
their
have send their logins to their friends
so that they while they were gone in
nature that someone else could keep
their streak for them yep
um so let's look at the example so this
is
one data session so you see if you go
back into your data you can see all of
your concessions your mind your heart
your body cool let's go into it yeah and
then you can save your notes in there
yeah yeah yeah so this is what it would
look like after you meditated so during
meditation you get your real-time
feedback and then after meditation
you're actually able to see what your
brain was doing during course calm
active yeah and neutral so up here is
when you're active and down here is when
you're calm so this individual
this individual started in a kind of
neutral place and then they had a
thought oh
and then they were like oh I'm having a
thought let me bring it back and then
they have another thought they brought
it back they got even calmer than when
they started you're able to stay in that
column had another thought sort of
fought with it brought it down stayed in
calm had a thought and then
and what we celebrate
is to get calm points and the calm
points come just from the amount of time
that you're in calm
um recoveries are when you notice that
your mind is wandered and you've
returned so when your mind spikes up
into active and you're like nope I see
that I'm
wondering let me bring it back and so we
celebrate the recoveries because it
doesn't really matter how many times
your brain spikes the key is that you've
noticed recoveries are huge yeah yeah
recoveries are huge and then birds and
that's always everybody's favorite
feature when you're able to stay for
five seconds or more in calm stay yeah
you get a bird you hear a little
oh and that becomes this incredibly
rewarding experience the funny thing
about that is like with like and then
it's also there it's undermine
yeah but it's also there to undermine
the reward-driven nature of this so
we're like okay well this is reward
driven but meditation is inherently
against rewards yeah yeah so we created
birds as a way to subvert that in a
sense so you sit there you get a bird
the first time you get a bird and you
don't know what it means fine you just
got a bird doesn't mean anything as soon
as you find out that it was a reward the
next time you get a bird you're like I
got a bird as soon as you get excited it
flies away so words are a way of
teaching you to be as uninvested in your
rewards as your failures to not get
excited to not get engaged in its it's
reward but it doesn't matter it's just a
sound it's just a sensation it's just an
experience
so a bird
a bird you hear the bird after five
seconds of being in calm and then it
flies away
or it stays it's key the bird stays
there if you stay in calm longer yeah so
if you get excited by the bird the bird
flies away interesting so you're
training people to not get excited by a
reward yep okay I get it it's our way of
subverting the goal directed nature sure
it's like fine there's a reward and it
doesn't matter it's very interesting
yeah it's interesting to learn about all
this stuff after you know hearing all
the do not react do not crave yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's funny
um this is really really well made yeah
this is well made
you see all your meditations here you
know see your total minutes
points Birds recoveries this week's goal
all that good stuff right there
and it's a motivational architecture
that's meant to keep you coming back and
meditating every day so we start with
this you know extrinsic gamified let's
give you Awards and badges
um and then ultimately the mere purpose
of that is to get you to come back and
meditate the next day and the next day
after that yeah and ultimately all of
that stuff melts away and doesn't matter
and what you speak into then experience
is the intrinsic reward of meditation
yeah the Sensation that you have in your
life because you meditate and then the
desire to come back and meditate
ultimately because you feel better but
it takes you a fair amount of time to
get there yeah to get to the point where
you have a significant enough meditation
practice to feel the shift in your day
yeah
now so we had to you know create a bunch
of structure to get you there yeah yep
unless you have a zen master with a
stick yeah yeah
me is we get that info now so when you
pay 249 for the Muse to
the app is free great and you can't have
the app if or the app is free
if you don't have a muse or the app is
also free if you don't have any music so
anybody can just go and download
the news and use the timer feature timer
feature yeah and we will have actually
more and more guided meditations inside
we just merged with a company called
meditation Studio yeah you did and
awesome and so they were the number
essentially number four up in the
meditation app store great
um so they have petition Studio yeah
they're beautiful beautiful content they
have over 500 different meditations for
everything you need in life and so you
know you need to fall asleep there's a
library of 10 meditations to help you
sleep from a range of different teachers
you're sitting on the bus and getting
frustrated because you're late for your
appointment there's a meditation for
that too we're a student and you're
about to take an exam and you're feeling
jittery like there's there's a
collection of meditations for students
wow specifically and so there's all of
these meditations for any moment in your
life that you're really targeted yeah
it's amazing it's been like it's become
my best friend yeah whenever I feel you
know whenever I want some morning Joy
like there's yeah there's a meditation
for that yeah that's that's very
interesting there's uh you know there's
a meditation for that that's funny
yeah yeah cool yeah there's a meditation
for that and so all of that content's
flowing into into me so you'll see that
flourishing over time
so where does this go does this get
smaller and more
channels on the headsets more sensor
it's gonna stay like this for a while
yeah yeah yeah what are we talking with
like long future stuff because how many
people are using this right now
tons and tons and tons like hundreds of
thousands hundreds of thousands or
millions and millions and millions of
sessions of sessions but like hundreds
of thousand people are using it yeah
there's wow and everybody from you know
your average individual using it because
they want to sleep better or they're
having relationship difficulties or they
want to be better in the workplace yeah
yeah to companies we do corporate
programs and we come in with a
compliment of Muses and get teams musing
together
I feel like I don't I like I don't want
to be a Luddite you know it's like
luddites are really bad but like there's
just there's also something very
interesting like there's so many people
being on boarded with this it's
fantastically getting more people
meditating it's going into corporate
environments all this kind of stuff
we have psychotherapists that use it we
have
we have like thousands and thousands of
professional psychotherapists
psychiatrists life coaches
naturopaths who use Muse in their
practice
doctors clinics Mayo Clinic has been
running a study using these for breast
cancer patients who've been awaiting
surgery and they get amused to deal with
the stress of surgery and hopefully also
improve their recovery times
so in all of those situations I was a
psychotherapist and so I try to teach my
patients to meditate but it never really
worked that well so in all of these
situations where
a professional wants to teach or
encourage their clients to meditate like
a doctor somebody comes in with a
condition that you know you should
recommend meditation for but the doctor
never knows how to meditate so the
patient certainly isn't going to know
how to meditate they're going to go home
they're not going to see their doctor
for another four months and they're not
going to meditate and now literally the
doctor can hand the patient to Muse and
say hey like go do this and I'm going to
know when you do it yeah and by the way
with your permission
can't know if you don't give me
impression but if you want to do this
within the you know within a client
patient relationship yeah
um then you can give me permission to
coach you in this process or if not just
take it take it home I'll never know but
you can go and meditate and then they
get at home and their wife starts using
it and then their kids start using it
I've heard so many beautiful stories of
kids who now meditate because of news a
guy was just telling me today yeah these
two kids he brought them home
they like would never do anything their
dad wanted them to do but he's like
here's this cool thing try to get some
birds and the kids started competing and
before you know it they were meditating
and it's been three years and they
meditate regularly now
yeah it does seem like there's way too
many benefits that outweigh there's
probably the only I think the literally
the only bad thing is that it just
we're no longer relying on just
ourselves to get us to states of of
meditation and like eradicating our own
suffering and misery but now we're all
using technology to augment headspace
and calm and Muse and all the a lot of
the other companies here which is which
is I think that's great like I said is
just onboarding so many more people like
you were saying it's like it's
biohacking is what it's doing and so we
don't want to wait for you for our own
abilities it's like no like let me
biohack myself to meditative States so
it's it's a trajectory of the future you
don't want to be left behind because so
we are still relying on ourselves to get
to States so Muse is not zapping you in
any way it's not you know but even
forcing your brain to do something even
something as simple as
hearing storms when Minds wandering
versus
having to detect that the mind is
wandering yourself which you which you
ultimately then need to do in your daily
life so you're going to meditate for
maybe 10 minutes
and then you're going to take it off and
then you're going to go into your life
and then you're going to start doing
things and you're going to take that
meditation fraction
99.99999 of the time yeah you have to do
it yourself you have to do it yourself
yeah this is just showing you what you
were supposed to do yeah yeah this is a
good way to look at it this is a really
well explained you can tell you've been
talking about it for 10 years you know
and if you don't want to meditate with
Muse and you want to figure it out on
your own fantastic please please please
just go meditate I truly do not care how
you do it whether you use technology or
don't use technology if you're against
technology no problem so long as it
doesn't mean that you're not meditating
yeah please it's very beneficial to you
it's very beneficial to everybody around
you so just get into the practice why
not whoever works for you is totally
fine with me yes why not why not like
how many other competitors are there
there's like a motive right what are the
other ones
um so motive it's not so much a
competitor in the meditation space they
have a
with more channels to it it sort of
takes up more real estate on your head
yeah and they're looking more at like
learning cognition and not inside their
company so I can't tell you exactly yeah
yeah that's also an awesome company yeah
neurosky and they really focused on like
the sort of single Channel like really
kind of low Market Low End Market yeah
morgany yeah
um with much simpler algorithms
and that's still about it okay and then
so I know it's not going to get smaller
for a while but the general idea is more
sensors smaller units longer battery
life and more Acquisitions or
collaborations with different companies
it seems like the general like roadmap
onboarding more people around the world
to help them use it and their kids use
it so my secret mission is to teach
everybody that you don't have to be
subject to the thoughts that are in your
head about you that say nasty things
about you all the time that's a good one
like yeah we are these amazing
phenomenal beings
but apparently 85 percent of the world
has low self-esteem like most of us just
feel a little bit unhappy about
ourselves and our condition and our
world most of the time and that is not
because the reality of us it's the story
that we tell ourselves yeah and so you
have the opportunity to change the
relationship between the thoughts that
are in your mind like for most people
your thoughts just think you and that's
not actually the way it needs to be you
can shift that relationship with your
own thoughts and choose the contents of
your mind choose the story of yourself
and choose what you want to do in your
life
beautifully said thank you it's totally
true yeah that's what 2000 years of
meditation technology has been telling
us yeah
yeah exactly yeah that we don't need to
suffer yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah I'm
I'm really happy that you're building
this and that you know you're
celebrating what I'm used to it's
fantastic it's great it's great to have
so many people that are caring about
this and putting it together
um congrats huge congratulations we'll
have to explore doing a promo code
that would be fantastic awesome we'll
see how well it does try and get you
guys signed up with me as soon as
possible
um thanks everyone for tuning in Arielle
thank you for coming thank you my
pleasure please check the bio for Muse
information and for the and for the link
uh with promo code we'll explore with
Slash simulation maybe we'll see
hopefully that's what it will end up
doing
um I'll let you know we'll have to I'll
let you know how it goes using this as
well I'll uh I'll have to get one and
and uh and give you guys feedback on on
how it goes
uh thank you thank you thank you for
coming on to the show my pleasure this
is great really really fun and thanks
for onboarding so many people into the
meditation experience yeah yeah thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it give us some comments
below with your thoughts we'd love to
hear from you
and go and build the future manifest
your destiny into the world thanks
everyone for tuning in and we'll see you
soon
peace